[Music]
welcome to Jerry Jian his photography
training Jerry key onus is widely
considered to be one of the top wedding
photographers in the world he's also a
Nikon ambassador and PDN name Jerry is
one of the top photography workshop
instructors in the world so if you want
to learn from one of the best masters in
our industry here's what you can expect
jerry began building this program in
2008 and because of that you'll have
access to one of the most extensive
libraries that is updated with brand new
content every single week one of the
best ways to learn how to shoot a
wedding is to virtually assist Jerry and
stand right there alongside him there
are well over a hundred video lessons in
the wedding section alone so you'll be
able to watch Jerry in action see all
the final images along with all of the
EXIF data if you're a portrait
photographer you'll have access to
numerous video lessons featuring client
portrait sessions as well as personal
projects
Jerry won the Australian fashion
photographer of the Year award recently
and you'll be able to learn from a
variety of stylized fashion shoots and
boudoir photographers will enjoy
learning how to make your subjects look
and feel beautiful in front of the
camera you'll be able to take advantage
of Jerry's skills and expertise by
learning his methods on how to pose male
subjects females and couples from
head-to-toe you'll also be able to study
Jerry's simple yet dramatic lighting
techniques using a variety of lighting
sources including window light sunlight
on and off-camera flash strobes and so
much more
every week you'll get to enjoy exclusive
interactive weekly live broadcast just
for members with topics that are often
chosen by you our library contains
business marketing and sales courses so
you can have a profitable studio - and
we have so many photo walks where you
can follow Gerry on location using the
elements all around him you'll get to
see exactly why he is known as a master
of turning the ordinary into the
extraordinary so what are you waiting
for now's the time to invest in your
future and become a better wedding and
portrait photographer start learning
today on your favorite device and at
your own pace let's become better
photographers together
[Applause]